I go home that night I start packing my
bags and I was dating this this chick
named uh Rebecca Hal we've been dating
about a month
and she shows up at my house you know I
hadn't retir at our phone calls all day
and apparently we were supposed to go
out and I'd forgotten about it I had
bigger issues and so I'm packing a
couple of duffel bags and she walks in
and she's like what's going on I'm like
um I'm leaving where you going I thought
we were supposed to go outside should go
do something tonight I'm like I'm
leaving it's over and and she says what
happened I tell her what happened this
is what happened she's like oh my God
like she had no idea well she had no
idea about anything you were doing no I
barely knew her like I mean she's coming
over two three times a week for a month
like I've you know this isn't love this
isn't you know this is a booty call
that's all it is like we're hanging out
we're having sex and that's it I don't
even know you
so she suddenly just begs to come with
me you got to bring me with you you have
to this you have to that I'm like what
are you talking about like you you've
got a you've got a son you have your mom
lives here you're and she's just in
tears and crying and she suddenly said
and this is what's so funny about is
that she had just moved
from Vegas to to um St Petersburg to
work at the dog track to work for a
company that owned the dog track right
the a casino interest or yeah like a
gambling company and uh she said you
don't even know why I'm here I was like
okay why are you here she said I'm here
because I was working for a law firm
that worked for the the um Casino
company that I work for she
said I got caught embezzling nothing it
was like 10 or $15,000 from my
boss because she had a gambling habit
and she said he didn't call the police
because we were sleeping together and he
was afraid his wife would find out she
said so instead he banished me here to
St
Pete my son just came to live with me
he's been caught sneaking out uh because
her the father had raised him he'd only
been living with her since she got to
Florida and she's like I was about I was
going to send him back he's failing
school he's smoking pot he's been caught
sneaking out after curfew I'm like okay
I I don't know any of this she's like he
was going back in December you well no
he was going back after the school year
which would have been like May okay and
I'm like so where before five minutes
earlier I thought she was this sweet
secretary sweet innocent
secretary and and she's like you know
I've been married three times I'm a
gambler I've playing bankruptcy I'm
sleeping with my old boss I got like you
know she went from this you know
thieving
adulteress you know and I thought these
are all really beneficial to my you know
my future plans yeah you know and I
shouldn't have at that moment you know I
was so just flipped out and concerned
and up and leaving your life and
everything you know
behind that's a that's terrifying and
you know and and so now you're alone in
a strange place in a place this the
first time you've done something like
that like leave to go on the road yes so
I never just up and moved and and keep
in mind now I can't call home I can't
like I'm I'm leaving there there are
things that I feel like get you caught
and every you know I've watched tons of
these TV shows and you know there are
certain things that get you caught you
know one of them is keeping in contact
with anybody in your old life so I'm
thinking that's that's not going to
happen like I'm not I'm not contacting
anybody I'm leaving and that's it that
didn't really happen I kept in touch I
called my mom every once a while but I
was like
um okay that's cool did the loneliness
of that hit you early on or no like as
you packing I never did
well you're leaving your life I mean
there's a it feels like a fundamental
transition oh listen you think I mean
listen not just that like I'm leaving my
my son I have a son and I'm you know I
was I was leaving everything I was just
terrified of going going to prison and
you know I
mean I don't it was just it was just so
stupid it was just arrogance and you
know I should have stayed like I made
things so much worse but I I also
thought I'm
smart I can I can figure this out like I
can change my identity blend in I'll be
fine aren't you already like people know
what your face looks like they do they
do but I one of the first things I did
was I got plastic surgery what what kind
of plastic surgery I've got I've got a
nose job I got uh what they call a mini
face lift they go in through your back
of your ears and they suck out all the
fat in your neck does that change
appearance much uh a little bit um I got
I was balding I got two hair transplants
you know two hair graphs so the hair in
my head least in my hair it's my hair
but it's from back here so there's they
cut it from here I appreciate it um so
they reimplanted it there uh you know
got lipos suction just some you know
other stuff and you know got my teeth
done that sort of thing you know
so you know and I that's was kind of
like my plan I'll go I'll take off I got
80 grand I'll steal some more money you
know but I I let her come with me and we
ran up all my credit cards over the next
few days packed up the car traded in my
my Audi and got like an Audi I know was
it like an A6 or like a four-door like
the big four-door whatever it was um got
that and uh drove straight to
Atlanta and and
um so I I wrote a letter to my parents
before I left just explaining this is
what's happening I'm leaving I'm done
I'm not going to
prison love you sorry sorry sorry sorry
sorry I'm I know I'm a disappointment
sorry
bam